the next topic on today's agenda is the
problem with Gen
Z the problem with Gen Z I'm gen Z I'm
so offended no I'm not offended there
are many many problems with my
generation today and we need to talk
about them we need to not be offended by
them we need to recognize what they are
so that we can be better and hopefully
not end up on a complete path to
destruction so let's see what this video
has in store for us 80s weren't perfect
but I'll tell you what they didn't have
there were no uh safe
spaces there were no trigger
warnings and there were no [__]
peanut
allergies why because for thousands of
years the only people who could have
children were ones who could hunt for
food build shelter and fight saber-tooth
tigers now they're there are people
having kids who can't eat
wheat but Christina it's an allergy you
don't
know well I do know I ain't [__] a
guy that's scared of
toast I was in stitches when I first saw
this video I think it's absolutely great
look I wasn't around in the 80s so I
have no idea what it was actually like
from personal experience but from what
I've heard from people who were around
in the 80s look it just seemed like a
much easier time the general consensus
which is to just be a bit soft and that
it's it's great to be soft we've
embraced the weakness of people in
today's society not only have we
embraced it but we we reinforce it you
know when when someone puts a trigger
warning on a video for some reason
that's seemingly normal now I don't
think it's the world's responsibility
to have to adhere to your triggers I
think your triggers are your
responsibility and it's up to you to be
able to filter out what you can and
can't take also how are we going to move
forward if we have to put trigger
warnings on everything if we've got
these people that are so easily upset
and hurt and offended that they need a
trigger warning on things what is that
what is that actually doing that's
wrapping them in Cotton wo that's not
exposing them to the real world that
that's putting them in a position where
they're never going to be able to handle
anything because they're so protected
from everything whereas if you got rid
of all the trigger warnings on things
and you just let people experience the
world as it is chances are a lot of them
would grow up PA a lot of them would get
over it just as people have done for
hundreds of thousands of years before
what scares me is the fact that one day
my generation the people now who are
what 18 to 25 are not going to be 18 to
25 they're going to be in their 30s 40s
50s and they're going to be the people
who are leading the world you know one
day someone who's in my generation could
be the next prime minister could be the
next president these people are going to
be on the board of directors these
people are going to be in the UN
and all of the other foundations that
are concerning at the moment anyway but
imagine when people of my gener ation
are in those positions of
power I think we ought to be very very
afraid of what that's going to look like
because I can't even imagine what kind
of mess that's going to be we need to we
need to get a grip we need to be
stronger we need to be better we need to
stop covering ourselves in Cotton wool
and thinking it's okay to be weak it's
not okay to be weak the real world is
Harsh the real world is going to throw
things at you you've got to learn to
roll with the punches otherwise you
won't survive uh I'm afraid it may not
seem like it in today's day and age with
everything that's so easy but it really
is survival of the fittest and you've
got to be the fittest and
today unfortunately that is being
emotionally fit you've you've got to be
able to to take things and you know
you've you've got to strive for better
you've got to strive for gold